[Musik]
nico ja ja ja besteht darauf dass bp sie
und ich auf unsere neuen lebensabschnitt
anschluss ein lebensabschnitt
ja weil wir alle in deutschland bleiben
und ich hoffe nicht bald im jahres laden
anfangen zu arbeiten
das ist ein iq möglich ich hätte gerade
ihm fast den sektor nebenbei nicht
bekommen die verkäuferin wollte mir die
flasche nicht verkaufen zumindest
millionen personalausweis hat sie nicht
geglaubt dass sie volljährig bist aber
ganz ehrlich sicheres für 17
das ist ein kompliment das sie
verkäuferin sich nach seinem ausweis
gefragt habt das ist eben jünger aus
reist du bist danke das war ein schöner
abend gestern ja das fand ich auch
ich vermisse dich nico dann treffen wir
uns morgen
nur kurz egal wie aber ich muss dich
sehen
die schreiben
[Musik]